we've seen in several videos that the
column space
column
space of a matrix is pretty
straightforward to find in this
situation the column space of a
is just equal to all of the linear
combinations of the column vectors of a
so it's equal to oh another way of
saying all of the linear combinations is
just the span
of each of these column vectors so you
know we call this one right here
a1 this is a2 a3 a4 this is a5
then the column space
of a is just equal to the span of a1
a2
a3
a4
and a5 fair enough
but a more interesting question is
whether these guys form a basis for col
for the column space or or even more
interesting what is the basis for the
columns base of a and in this video i'm
going to show you a method for
determining the basis and along the way
we'll get an intuition for maybe why it
works and if i have time actually i
probably won't have time in this video
in the next video i'll prove to you why
it works so what you do to figure out
the the basis so we want to figure out
the basis
for
the column space of a remember the basis
just means that vectors span
vectors span
c a clearly these vectors span our
column space i mean the span of these
vectors is the column space but in order
to be a basis the vectors also have to
be linearly let me just write
linearly independent and we don't know
what whether these guys or what subset
of these guys are linearly
independent so what you do and i'm just
really going to describe the process
here as opposed to the proof is you put
this guy in reduced row echelon form so
let's do that
so let me
let's see if we can do that let's keep
our
first row the same
one
zero
let me do it actually on the right side
right here so let's keep the first row
the same one zero minus one zero four
and then let's turn our let's replace
our second row with the second row minus
two times the first row
so then our second row two minus two
times one
is zero
one minus two times zero is one
zero minus two times negative one zero
minus so that's zero plus two
zero minus two times zero is just zero
and then 9 minus 2 times 4 is 1. fair
enough
now we want to zero out this guy well it
seems like a pretty straightforward way
just add replace this row with this row
plus the first row so minus 1 plus 1 is
2 plus 0 is 2
5 minus 1
is 4
plus 0 is 1
minus 5 plus 4
is minus 1. and then finally we got this
guy right here and then maybe we can
just in order to zero him out let's
replace him with him minus the first row
so 1 minus 1 is
zero
minus one minus zero is minus one
minus three minus negative one that's
minus three plus one so that's minus two
minus two
minus zero is minus two
and then 9 minus 4
is 5. so we did one round
we got our first
we got our first pivot column going
now let's do another round
of
row operations well we want to zero all
of these guys out luckily this is
already zero
so we don't have to change our first row
our second row so we get one
zero minus one zero four
our second row becomes zero
one
two zero one
and now let us see if we can eliminate
this guy right here and let's do it by
replacing our blue row our third row
with the third row minus two times the
second row so zero minus two times zero
is zero two minus two times one is zero
four minus two times two is zero
one minus two times zero is one
minus one minus two times one is minus
three
all right
now this last guy we wanna eliminate him
and the we wanna turn this into a zero
we just let's replace this fourth row
with the fourth row plus the second row
so zero plus zero is zero minus one plus
minus one is zero minus two plus minus
two is zero
minus two
plus zero is minus two
and then five plus one is six
five plus one is six
we're getting close
so let's see we have this let's look at
our pivot entries
we have this is a pivot entry that's a
pivot entry and this is not a pivot
entry and let's see because it's
following obviously another this guy is
a pivot entry right here or will be we
need to zero this minus two out so let's
i think we'll be done so let me write my
first row just the way it is because
everything above it is zero so we have
to worry about it so my first row i can
just write as
one
zero
minus one
zero four i can write my second row
zero
one two
zero one i can write my third row as
zero zero zero
one minus three and now let's replace my
fourth row
let's replace it with it plus two times
the second row so zero plus two times
zero
zero plus two times zero zero plus two
times zero minus two plus two times one
is just zero
six plus two times minus three that's
six minus six that's just zero and there
we have we've we've
actually
put our matrix in reduced row echelon
form so let me put a little brackets
around it
it's not so bad if you just kind of go
and and just do the manipulations and
sometimes when you you kind of get a
headache thinking about doing something
like this but this wasn't too bad so
this is the reduced let me just say the
reduce row echelon form of a let me just
call that matrix r so this is matrix r
right there
now what do we see about matrix r well
it has three pivot entries or three
pivot columns let me square them out or
circle them out
column one is a pivot column
column two is a pivot column
and column
three is a pivot column
now
and we've done this in previous videos
you can you can well there's two things
that you can see
these three columns they're clearly
linearly independent how do we know that
well this guy's got a one where and
that's just with respect to each other
if we just took a set of let's call this
r
one
r two
and this would be r r3 this would be r4
right here
it's clear that the set
r
r 2
and r 4
it's clear that this is linearly
independent and you say why is that well
look r1 has got a one here while the
other two have a zero in that entry
right and this is by definition of pivot
entries pivot entries have zeros or
pivot columns have zeros everywhere
except for where they have a one so any
if if for any pivot column it will be
the only pivot column that has zeros
there or it will be the only pivot
column that has a one there so there's
no way that you can add up combinations
of these guys to get a one you could say
100 times 0 minus 3 times 0 you're just
going to get a bunch of zeros so no
combination of these two guys is going
to be equal to that guy
by the same reasoning no combination of
that and that is going to equal this
this is by definition of a pivot entry
by no when you put it in reduced row
echelon form it's very clear that any
pivot column will only will be the only
one to have one in that place so it's
very clear that these guys are linearly
independent now it turns out and i
haven't proven it to you that the
corresponding columns in a so the
correspond this is r1 but at a before we
put in reduced row echelon form that
these guys right here
so a1
a2
and
a4
are also linearly independent
so a1
let me circle a1 a2 and a4 so if i write
it like this a1 a2
and a4
let me write in set notation
these guys are also
linearly independent which i haven't
proven but i think you can kind of get a
sense that these row operations really
don't change the sense of the matrix and
i'll do a better
explanation of this but i really just
wanted you to understand how to develop
a basis for the column space so they're
linear independent and so the next
question is do they span do they span
our column space and in order for them
to span obviously all of these five
vectors if you have all of them that's
going to span your column space by
definition but if we can show and i'm
not going to show it in this video but
it turns out that you can always
represent this the free the non-pivot
columns so you can always represent the
non-pivot columns as linear combinations
of the pivot columns and we'll show and
we've kind of touched on that in
previous videos where we find the
solution for the null space and all of
that
so these guys can definitely be
represented as linear combinations of
these guys i haven't shown you that but
if you take that as kind of as on faith
then you don't need that column that
column to span if you if you did then
i guess a better way to think it you
don't need them to span although they
are part of the span because if you
needed this guy you can just construct
them with linear combinations of these
guys so if you wanted to figure out a
basis for the column space of a you
literally just take aim to reduce row
echelon form you look at the pivot
entries in the reduced row echelon form
of a and that's those three and then you
look at the corresponding columns to
those pivot columns in your original a
and those form the basis because any
linear combination of them or linear
combinations of them can be used to
construct the non-pivot columns and
they're linearly independent so i
haven't shown you that but for this case
if you want to know the basis it's just
these three vectors sorry it's just
a1 a2 and a4
and a4 right there and now we can answer
another question
so let me say so the basis
so
a1
a2
and a4
form a basis
basis
for
the column space of a
because you can construct the other two
guys with linear combinations of our
basis vectors and they're also linearly
independent now and the next question is
what is the dimension of the basis or
what is the dimension not the dimension
of the basis what is the dimension
of the column space
of a well the dimension is just the
number of vectors in any basis for the
column space and all basis have the same
number of vectors for any given subspace
so we have one two three vectors so the
dimension of our column space is equal
to three and the dimension of a column
space actually has a specific term term
for it and that's called the rank
so the rank
of a which is the exact same thing as
the dimension of the column space
it is equal to three and another way to
think about it it's the number the rank
of a is the number of linearly
independent column vectors that you have
that can span your entire column space
or the number of linearly independent
column vectors that can be used to
construct all of the other column
vectors but hopefully this didn't
confuse you too much because the idea is
very simple take a put it into reduced
row echelon form see what your pivot
your see which which row columns are
pivot columns the corresponding columns
are going to be basis are going to be a
basis for your column space if you want
to know the the rank for your matrix you
can just count them or even if you don't
want to count those you could literally
just count the number of pivot columns
you have in your reduced row echelon
form so that's how you do it in the next
video i'll explain why this worked